hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the charity cup we said that
we were going to cover at least one more
game it's magnus cross and with the
white pieces against young shisht of
duda in the previous video uh you've
seen what happened in game two game one
ended in a draw we discussed that game
too
magnus one with the black pieces and now
if magnus wins this one uh it's a game
over or rather it's a a win for magnus
on the first day as the finals is
decided over two days so there will be
uh the second part of the finals today
so let's um
uh see what happened i can do that get a
win with the black pieces or maybe hold
magnus to a draw here and then uh go for
one more uh white uh game uh in game
four to try and claim a win uh magnus
now has the white pieces and he opens
with c4 and yes we did not have a
positive video moment in the previous
video so we are going to have two in
this video i think you guys will
appreciate these uh two very much so
knight to f6 we have knight to c3 uh e5
by do dot knights to f3 and knight to c6
we have the four knights variation of
the english uh g3 and the bishop to b4
now so this is a very a very uh common
line knights to d5 now attacking the
bishop thing that if you capture i'm
going to capture back kick away or
knight and then win the e5 pawn so
basher back to c5 and now bishop to g2
both players castle so castles castles
d6 and now e3 uh bishop to g4 fighting
for the center not allowing whites to
play and d4 and now magnus challenges
the bishop and says all right you are
welcome to capture here so bishop to h5
g4 bishop to g6 and now as there is no
more pressure on the knight here so you
are once again fighting for the center
uh we executed d4
so challenging the bishop now on c5
bishop back to b6 and here knight
captures and b6 with a captures on b6
and there is a game in the database
where b3 was played but here we have
knight to h4 by magnus and it is now as
of move 13 that we have a completely new
game and it's very interesting what the
knight is doing here so you might be
interested in capturing the bishop
knight the f5 might be an idea in some
lines but also you have to be very
careful if black moves this night then
you're just going to lose your knight on
h4
luckily for magnus or not luckily as he
calculated this out
there are no useful discoveries with
this knight so you can't really just
move it anywhere and pick up this knight
for it to be good for black so here
bishop to e4 duda would very much like
to trade a bishop for a bishop not a
bishop for a knight so magnus plays f3
and now knight to d7 and now he opens up
the attack he says all right you can
capture the bishop here but at least
your king's king's uh pawn structure
around your king will be a little bit
ruined so f captures on e4 magnus goes
for this queen captures on h4 and now
bishop to d2 uh preparing to re-maneuver
the bishop over here kick away the queen
maybe put the bishop on g3
could be could be good for for white so
the queen to h6 now not allowing this as
the e3 pawn would fall and a4 now we
have to play a4b3 to solidify everything
on the queen side and then we're going
to shift our attention towards the
king's side we have rook f to e8 and now
d5 so closing the center as well knight
to e7 and now queen to f3 now okay the
pawn is guarded you might be able to
put your bishop somewhere else we have
rook to f8 and now b3 now this rook can
also come into the game you don't have
to keep it here to guard the a4 pawn
knight to c5 going after the b3 pawn and
for the moment rook a to b1 so not the
greatest square for the rook but we are
expecting
uh at some point that black will also
want to activate his rook then maybe we
will be able to push some pawns and then
reactivate this rook so knight to g6 now
the knight can come to the h4 square so
queen to g3 uh now with some ideas of
maybe rook to f5 because if rook to f5
and then you put a knight to h4 then we
can put the rook to h5 and attack the
queen and the knight so of course duda
plays it right away he doesn't allow
rook f5 uh and now bishop the h1 and we
also kind of don't want to give away our
light square bishop it's an excellent
defender so just bishop to h1 we always
know that this is a very special
relationship between a bishop and the
knight where they cancel each other out
so taking away all of the squares that
the knight can use to go forward uh we
have g5 now guarding the knight now
again the queen can be moved and finally
bishop to e1 now magnus wants to move
the queen and pick up the knight with
bishop captures on h4 because this
knight is now well sort of a monster
night it's not controlling
the full eight squares only controls
four squares so it's maybe a half of a
monster night but still very very scary
so knights the d3 uh infiltrating with
the knight and uh now comes bishop to c3
so we're not interested in giving up our
bishop uh we have knight back to c5 and
now queen to h2 so this is how magnus
will now try to
get get the bishop over to e1 king to g7
now with ideas of f6 and finally bishop
to e1 going after this knight we have f6
and now shifting the queen over to c2
now guarding the the the b3 pawn or
rather guarding the a4 pawn because you
want to play b4 so you don't lose the
the a4 pawn we have knights to g6 and
now bishop to g2
we have knights to e7 and now pawn to b4
and this is now very very interesting uh
why why wouldn't black just capture the
pawn here on a4 well if you capture this
then we're gonna play rook to a1 and it
doesn't look all that all that great uh
what is your knight doing here how are
you how are you saving it where is the
knight going you're going to have to
play b5 we're going to play c captures
on b5 and now after knight to b6 for
example captures you're going to capture
back with the rook or or not with the
rook who you're going to capture with
the knight and now you will play queen
a2 infiltrate with the queen and that's
going to be great for white so instead
after b4 we have knight to d7 and now we
have a5 and this is a pawn push that you
should completely ignore however it's a
rapid game at time of course um
moves more rapidly here uh so duda
captured the pawn but now uh he loses
the defender of the c5 square and magnus
grabs that space with c5 and now the
problem is let's say play a capture some
b5 we're just going to play c captures
on b6 and after pawn captures queen c7
and here black's entire position just
falls apart the
everything just uh falls here so after
c5 we have queen to g6 duda now has to
resort to some very clever uh trickery
uh in defending uh and now after c
captures on d6 he finds knight captures
on d5 the pawn is now pinned as the
queen on c2 would hang if you capture so
the captures on c7 magnus gets this
beautiful pass pawn here but now duda
also gets a pass pawn he pushes a4 and
he is now uh well also pushing his past
pawn we have looked at d1 uh now putting
pressure on the knight here and knight
five to b6 so uh sorry uh knight five to
b6 uh i'm removing the knight uh also
defending the knight on d7 and now b5 so
now if the knights move then b6 is
coming and magnus will now have a
protected pass pawn on c7 so queen to f7
now guarding some additional squares
here we really want to start pushing
that that pawn and magnus starts
creating a blockade bishop to b4 now
takes away the a3 square we have rook
after c8 preparing to pile up on the c7
pawn and now rook to d3 with the idea of
guarding the a3 square
rook to c1 is more precise here because
rook the d3 allows duda a move dude did
not play but knight c4 here
is very impressive you are preparing to
capture on c7 and you basically force
white into this rook captures on d7
giving up rook for two nights which
should be good for you but then real
captures on c7 you lose this main asset
and now it's still black who has the
past eight pawn so this would with
perfect play of course uh be equal uh
but it's uh the
maybe uh the the most proper way to play
it however instead after this
uh instead of that we have rook to d3
and now a3 instead of knights to c4 so
duda continues pushing his pass pawn and
here magnus plays bishop captures on a4
and now knight to c4 so here
duda has a lot of threats but you guys
of course uh see right through them and
you know that there is uh uh well there
is one such a beautiful winning move
that this is only the first over to
pause the video moments so feel free to
pause the video and try to find the
absolute strongest move for white here
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
incredible idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's bishop
to d6 that's the good stuff and it's
very easy to realize why because black
is threatening rook captures in c7 and
also black is threatening knight
captures bishop here so if you combine
the two you're just going to play bishop
to d6 and that's it that's uh all there
is there's no way for black to make
progress here uh because we can either
capture this but if we capture then
white will just recapture and we are
nicely defending the spawn now we are
putting a lot of pressure on black's
position and there's just not all that
much you can play b6 is coming so this
is really ugly so the only thing after
bishop to d6 is for black to try
something like rook to a5 but still we
play bishop to b4 attack the rook now
force uh the rook to capture and now
let's say queen a4 uh there's simply too
much pressure the rook is hanging if you
move the rook then the knight hangs and
black really has nothing better than to
capture here and after queen captures
yes you get to capture on c7 but not
rook to c1 and white is completely
winning here there's no way out out of
this for black after you play something
we're just going to double up here rugby
to c3 and black resigns so bishop to d6
definitely the absolute strongest idea
here magnus goes for a different one he
plays rook captures on d7 i'm sure i
move a lot of you have decided to play
instead of this bishop to d6 brilliancy
uh queen captures on d7 now queen
captures on c4 and while this is also
very strong black will get some counter
play uh rook captures on a3 we have b6
now this is now
an incredible structure for white
and now rook to d3 uh not going for rook
captures an e3 rook captures an e3 is
also worth considering but okay dude has
a different plan rook to d3 rook to b1
adding a defender to his b pawn and now
rook to d2 and here magnus starts uh uh
well a sort of a a maneuvering saga with
this light square bishop that you guys
will really enjoy he plays bishop to f3
and duda plays queen to d6 put pressure
on the b6 pawn so the road cannot move
and it's not easy to find what what to
play here with white but there is one
move that uh well once you see it you
you simply start believing it uh feel
free to pause the video for the second
time and find this winning move for
magnus while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting that
black is actually without the move and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is bishop the e2 what uh
what a crazy winning move this is uh i
mean this is just insane but now when
you look at it what can black play there
is nothing for black to play here you
can't move the rook anywhere along the
second rank you can't play rook d1 you
can't move the rook somewhere useful
this is taking this stake and this is
taken so this rook also cannot move if
you move this rook we just push the pawn
to uh
to queen so the only move black really
has is is a silly pawn move which okay
we can discuss this let's say h6 now
white goes rogue b5 and now after rook
b5 there will be there will be trouble
for example king f8 we're going to play
king f2 we need to cover this pawn from
some ideas like queen a3 going after the
e3 pawn king g after
king of 2 king to g7 now we're going to
play rook d5 attack the rook attack the
queen and the ones this is traded off
captures captures black could capture on
b6 but not just queen d7 check we pick
up the rook and that's it once the king
moves we pick up the pawn and luckily
our bishop on e2 prevents the queen from
delivering any checks so we are
completely safe here we just move the
queen queen our pawn and game over so
this is one way to do it after bishop to
e2 duda chose the other way around he
played queen to a3 first now going after
the e3 pawn but now it's a
matter of a different move order king to
f2 guards the pawn now comes rook to d6
by playing queen to a3 okay you do give
the rook some uh squares on along the d
file
but it does not help here just queen to
b4 and what you play again the rook is
hanging the queen is hanging you have to
trade here captures captures was played
but now let's uh let's see how magnus
wins this uh we discussed that the
bishop started the magnificent
magnificent journey with this bishop to
f3 bishop to e2 idea now the bishop is
coming to d5 uh at the c4 to d5 and then
bishop captures and b7 will be played in
black black steel rooks are completely
helpless in stopping this so this is
just uh amazing bishop saga king to fate
bishop to c4 now king the e7 bishop to
d5 and now it's completely
uh irrelevant what to do that place he
played rook to it but magnus of course
didn't play bishop captures on b7 it
would be it would be crazy if you found
all of this i mean getting the bishop
here and then you captured on b7 now
because if you capture on b7 now
duda has rook to a to check and you have
to settle for a draw you have to play
king to e1 and now we just go rookie one
check rookie two check rookie one check
this rook prevents the king from going
over to the d-file because if you go up
the board after rookie two check if you
play king of three then rook d to d2 and
now duda would win the game magnus can
bring a queen of course into the game
but let's look at this rook f2 checking
g3 rook g2 king of three and of course
rook
f2 check will be checkmate so incredible
stuff but of course after rook to 88
magnus sports the trickery uh and uh
just plays uh rook to b2 and he was in
this position on move 51 that young
shisht of duda resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
the pawn will fall and that's just it
there's nothing you can do about it and
then of course c8 will be covered we're
going to push c8 we're going to queen
the pawn and that's it but just an
incredible bishop journey and uh well i
first thought only only of showing one
game from the from the finals but then
when i saw
this bishop's journey
i knew i had to show this one as well
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it tell everyone you know about
this great bishop and the journey it
made uh i would like to thank drippers
cyberclub nft uh blueberry friends
twitter rob rob antonio sharpfade and
david charlotte for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the finals
because this was only the first day of
the finals we also have the second day
of the finals uh so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your weekend